[Music]
[Music]
fire
stop
[Music]
this is really the fighter and the kid
we're out come on baby
Chin's in a trench coat today he you
that is a stylish flashers that's a
stylish flasher you look like a stylish
you look like a flasher who comes from
family money and I appreciate that
single now he's dressing a lot better
these days who makes that that jacket
it's a place called cause I don't know
if you guys heard I never know don't
know about it but uh someone I know she
wants to be a stylist so I said just
have at it and she gave me so Dad is
Daddy at 55 knows that girls are not not
a looking as much but once in a while he
gets he gets a little hungry eyes press
and I'm talking about Hunger ass from a
30 year old from a 28 year old yeah and
and my my wife my now wife and I are
hanging out and uh and there was a young
lady who gave me business in front of
the wifey well she didn't know I was my
wife was talking to other people oh and
uh Daddy was afraid and I was like
talking to this woman and I was like I'm
getting business here my wife goes That
Girl Was So Into You it was stupid I go
was she she goes yeah yeah you see her
face changed when I showed up and you
felt good this young lady had won the
old Rings the kids still got it the kid
well some angles yeah and sometimes I'm
wearing a certain color yeah the sandals
could be the conversation yeah you never
know could she be she's not in the looks
look we don't know did you notice it
before your wife said it
I did okay oh yeah but here's the other
thing Daddy I feel like Daddy has still
has a little physical I got some
physical Shake
Muhammad our boy Muhammad yeah with her
though yeah well no I was just going to
talk about my physical prowess that's
not it though I ran stairs about you you
know you know as Chris says there's
something about you I don't yeah you
know you get older and that's the way it
is
that's the way it is Buddy you post
about it all bro I'm sorry did you post
about it at all I I I did I posted a
little bit on my story but I shot a best
of with him where we ran the best guy
and then I had a long conversation about
what his training camp is like with
khabib here's what's interesting about
belong so he's number four now ranked
number four
took me to his house by the way to eat
outside Chicago yes yeah where we had a
Palestinian meal his dad his mom uh his
brother his brother's wife it was
[ __ ] amazing I mean great great
family he's such a good [ __ ] dude
solid dude and and he he told me like he
trained in that camp with khabib yeah
and khabib spent a lot of money a
million dollars correct to get my job
ready yeah correct yeah and then there
was food spreads but khabib was like and
Bilal was like what can I do to repay
you because you got the win that's all I
care about yep but the kind of training
they do nuts us and and Bilal was like
telling me that like khabib will be on
on top of you and talking having a
conversation with someone else yeah
Savage and it's like what the [ __ ] yeah
that's his training camp I'm curious
what they're gonna do with blog well
here's here's what's interesting about
definitely earned a legit title shot so
what what I thought was interesting is
you kind of remember his Palestinian the
Palestinians that he's their guy right
now there's not Palestinians don't have
a lot of people to look to who are on
the on the stage on the world stage so
when he's in the Arab world let me tell
you when he goes to Abu Dhabi no he's
massive I mean massive but when we're
running stairs there were there were
there were Egyptians and Palestinians
people there who were there and would
grab him and kiss him and start speaking
to him in Arabic and then calling their
friends on the phone yeah because he's
such a like but he can handle it he can
handle it well I thought you're gonna
say something about him who's fighting
next well
I don't know that they're I don't know
that he knows yet what do you think
I mean Darius if they want to kill us
you know and they've given him nothing
but Killers well I know you look at his
resume especially his last few wins he's
fighting the who's who can I can I let
me ask you this I don't know what you do
with him because you got the so Chandler
and uh Poirier so you got five and two
fighting next Saturday you'll see 281 in
uh New York by Square Garden Justin
gaichi's out with the nose and he's
fighting for ziv so then you got Darius
sitting there but derush wants uh
Charles Olivera
so you could do
um by the way he fights at 70. so we're
talking right now you're talking 55. oh
I'm sorry Jesus and I keep doing that
too I keep doing that too because khabib
wants him to go down to 55 but it's like
that's a that's a [ __ ] no I was
literally talking about do you use
that's my bet so dearish is gonna get
Oliver that's what they should do with
uh Muhammad uh the ish so you got Liana
Edwards and you got uh Usman fighting
you had Colby Covington hamzat fighting
does nothing really for him yeah there's
nothing there maybe just sit in the cut
for a little bit you're sitting for a
hot second cause Leon and Camaro is
fighting in England that year right
that's next year and then you got Kobe
hamzat and even announced so what do you
do if you're that guy maybe sit maybe
sit tight keep wrestling with those
dagestanis he's got a high fight IQ so
it looks like to me like he picks up on
[ __ ] right away it might I wouldn't say
goodbye to that go back I wouldn't be
surprised wait who's comes out fighting
he's fighting Colby yes the sole hom
thoughts but Kobe's book he'll take
he'll take the winner of that
we wanted to ask in title shot
no doubt it doesn't make sense so you'd
probably fight the loser of Camaro Leon
or loser of Kobe
how about Gilbert Burns that's a stacked
wake that's not though it's not because
after four
you know what do you do after five yeah
well no because Gilbert had his run
right yeah but he's tough but for
Muhammad it's like all right well you
know Gilbert Neil there Wonderboy
Thompson's uh fighting Sean Brady just
lost Vicente lot you know there's not a
ton form there unless
in which I don't think Jorge would do it
if they do like a big name like a Jorge
Mazda doll just for a big name I don't
know otherwise she's waiting till
third quarter next year that's fine
you're gonna fight the loser uh it's not
fine though it sucks why because income
too yeah and also ring you want to be
active but I don't know what he does
yeah because you're only gonna fight the
loser of Palms out Kobe or uh Leon
Edward zeusman
but the bummer for him yeah either way
Muhammad is a much more difficult task
to get a tile shot because I always
compare Muhammad and uh Darius they're
similar both four both on these streaks
they both fought everybody they both
deserve a title shot but dearish I can
see him with a much clearer path Todd
Shot posted Muhammad he just because
it's all tied up I I do think that if
you were to see Bilal Muhammad stand
next to
comes out well he's he's not a big 70
pounder thick legs I thought you were
gonna say Hamza and uh uh no Hamza is
way bigger yeah way bigger yeah and
that's what I'm saying bilal's got a
tail piece on him though I looked at him
and I was like you got an ass on you you
got an ass he's got some thick legs you
know he's a he's a dance dude yep did he
talk about uh his parents and with like
the protests going on and his dad on the
cell phones and they got raided and all
the BLM so his father you know Bill
spends his life building this amazing
this business with cell phone business
and and uh a nice like a Boost Mobile
type of thing where you get up and you
buy a minute and there was another part
to the store as well which was uh I
think a dry cleaners or something anyway
um so that's their income they're you're
talking about Palestinian refugee and
that they just it's life is not easy oh
and by the way came from Nothing by the
way please understand he grew up in the
south side of Chicago playing basketball
okay it's all it's like he was the
Palestinian guy everybody else is black
so he came up pretty hard and it was
always dangerous that they got they got
robbed at gunpoint he had a shotgun put
to his chest all that [ __ ] okay but
either way
um then the BLM March has come along and
they burned his [ __ ] store to the
ground
so but I thought they weren't what I
thought I thought it was peaceful oh no
no it's mostly peaceful mostly unless
you own a business yeah so then so then
you spend all your time 15 years my dad
support our family with this shop and
they [ __ ] destroyed it so you know
you can imagine uh heartbreak yeah and
that that's the problem with looting
it's it's indiscriminate and it sucks
but um either way he's a [ __ ] dude
who just you know you can he's such a
good guy and he's got and that's why
part of part of how he deals with all
the the pressure of being the face of
the Palestinians the face of you know
and there's this there's this a lot of
like uh Muslim people are coming up in
the UFC and winning and they're all kind
of training together yeah that's a lot
of pressure though so so but that's why
if I was the current UFC fighter convert
to Muslim right now I said you're gonna
have a lot of Americans to convert to
Islam Americans with like chin strap
beers unless you're Jon Jones all you
should convert to Muslims and jump into
that camp well so so so uh Muslims are
coming that well that's why he goes he
goes to mosque man they would all pray
together so with khabib he said that the
bond that they had where they'd all sit
there and they would all pray at the
same time that's some discipline that's
some discipline be tough to beat well
you're filing for hours that's gonna be
tough to be and they're all very good
well that's like that could be what
would he always do he could point to
himself and go not me and he points yeah
a lot training that [ __ ] said
Kabir said if you if you want this if
you want it you train and you can train
three days three or three times a day
pray Eat Sleep Train but it's up to you
it's up to you it's very simple yeah I
know we said that but um no he did yeah
say that that's what he said on there's
actually a video of him saying that but
also that's what he says you're saying
when oh yeah but I'm saying yeah khabib
said this to matcha before he's being
champ we got he's the main event and
Mike Jeff hates the interviews on that
and could be good oh yeah buddy you can
lose you just lose it all goes away and
he said he's like but he's being nice he
goes it's very simple just look he's got
a great idea this all goes away yeah and
he wasn't being like hostile he's just
like hey did you hear uh Jeremiah I mean
do you hear Islam go uh Daniel Cormier
is nice I mean what I'm gonna do is is
black belts then then I'm good
ah come on brother you know bro I'm bar
you know guys what's the the role Granby
Rose nothing what what I'm gonna do with
this it's offensive it's effective it's
logisticated effective there's another
way I want some Olympic level guys
Jordan Burroughs because yeah bring him
you know yeah he's a marketer Islam I
can you got Jordan Burroughs he goes
well brother he has double leg nothing
and it's all just double leg what I'm
gonna do with this [ __ ] let's take a
break let's take a little break from
solving all the problems I'm our
conspiracy talk what is the first thing
you do when you wake up do you check
your credit score okay probably not I
take a hard PM that I think about my
credit I'm like man I wish there was
something better out there like chime
well chime they have secured chime
credit Builder Visa credit card you
start building credit with your own
money okay wow chime reports your
payments to credit bureaus to help you
build credit over time their members see
an increase of 30 points on average and
they're a lot no annual fees large
security deposits or credit checks to
apply wow start your credit Journey with
chime sign up takes only two minutes
doesn't affect your credit score get
start at chime.com fighter that's chime
chime.com the chime credit Builder Visa
crew credit cards issue described bank
and a pursuant of a license with vs us
at a time checking account and 200
qualifying direct deposit required to
apply for the secured chime credit
Builder Visa credit card regular on-time
payment history can have a positive
impact on your credit score impact the
score May Vary and some use scores may
not improve out of network ATM
withdrawal fees May apply except at
MoneyPass ATMs uh in a 7-Eleven or at
Ally point or VISA plus Alliance ATM I
hope you guys heard that if you're still
if you're still listening chime.com your
head has not hit the ground yet from
boredom all right
now dude were you able you were on stage
during the Jake Paul fight the Jake Paul
no sir I came off in fact I'll be honest
with you I cut my set a little short I
had to run it so I missed the first
round and I saw the best person I am a
bad person but I had to see that dude I
did the Thomas fight command with uh
Jesse on fire who you got to meet you
love him yeah was he a fighter he looks
good enough okay he's just uh like a MMA
has a kickboxing too that's a video yeah
not fighter though right so uh I hate
when people do that no he took three
kickboxing classes right right so not a
fighter but very educated on fighting
does roll some right so that's cool but
he's you know he has his [ __ ]
master's degree in MMA like he's a great
personality on thing that's how I met
him I liked his content I was like you
should do companions like yep let's do
it and then we had Frank Mayer Who was
great came with his wife and then uh the
great Sam Tripoli the great Sam tripling
who got the episode demonetized but
absolutely love him and I apologize to
him let him get him demonetized so uh
Sam did his thing but you know before we
were doing it and I'm not too Mountain
horn I get a bunch of stuff wrong
but I kind of went how I thought it was
going to go uh you know I thought he was
going to kind of struggle early he's
going to struggle early because of the
the technical uh advantage that Emerson
has and the pressure and he's not used
to that and you know he struggled a
little early especially when answers
going forward but he was still hanging
in there you know and then when he began
against the roaches trouble for him and
then I said so he would struggle early
on and then eventually you know being
the quicker more powerful fighter Jake's
gonna land and I thought he's gonna
knock him out after the six I said
knockout and you know still won in the
fight 10-8 round yeah but you know he
did his thing well I think what I got
was first of all that you want to talk
about Improvement two and a half years
of boxing and you're that good that's
what I say in the shop okay the biggest
thing should be I mean if you're
fighting whoever's next he didn't know
how to throw a punch it didn't wasn't
they end in that epoxy he didn't have a
throat punch watch him you know that
video of him hitting mitts when he had
his first fight you ever seen that yeah
but but the the point is is like if your
answer let's say he fights an eight Diaz
next we can talk about that but with
Anderson Silva you know his team I'm
sure studying film on Jake the the
disadvantage you have whoever's fighting
whether it's Nate next you're not
fighting that guy he's so young on the
sport and trains his ass off and kudos
to his coaches you're finding completely
different guy if because it's his
Infinity of his career you're getting
ready for this guy but now he's made the
adjustments he's this guy now you're
like well we didn't train for this [ __ ]
here's the thing he's also like I I
think he's a legit athlete
I mean I think he's very athletic for
sure and I think that he hits [ __ ]
hard he's he's so so he kind of puts his
head down and just boom just he can also
take a shot that's that's what we
learned I this is best case scenario for
Jake because if he went in there and
starts Anderson let's say in 10 seconds
well the entire narrative today Monday
morning Halloween morning is Ashton's
old what is Jake doing picking on these
oldies they look great but Anderson
beating him some rounds put him in uh
compromising positions and then Jake
having to fight and we actually still
said adjust adjust and then win rounds
and rounds were close and he's getting
rocked and then also you know my
question is cardio like we saw he he had
the power in eighth round he had the
card all the all the answers were
checked this is the best case scenario
for Jake did what happened best I mean
if he would have knocked around they had
been fun but the way it went is almost
perfect for breaking down knocked
Anderson Silva down man that's a big
deal tough to do
and and uh so do you think so so next I
I assume it's gonna be Nate Diaz and
excuse my problem this is me and Frank
this this is Frank Mayer I mean Frank
you know a thing or two about fighting
yeah before this fight
I was always on the the mountain of
Jake you don't want Nadia the pressure
the volume he brings it's not going to
be good after watching that I looked at
Frank because Frank was shot was like Oh
my he was not rooting for Jake his wife
sure as [ __ ] was it because they're UFC
to the day they die they want Ashton win
after I finally your friend's face I
knew where he was at and I go real quick
and as they're reading off because I
knew he's gonna go Nate uh versus Jake
who he got in Pringles uh Jake in every
way Jake and he goes matter of fact I
didn't say Connor's gonna have some
issues after watching that 100 exactly
he's like Nate's gonna have some issues
he goes I don't think Nick's gonna be
favored in that fight God I was like I
think he's gonna be some problems well
you got to understand something I mean a
lot of this is physics you're talking
about he's a big guy Jake is probably
200 pounds walking around okay and he's
also a strong 200 pounds and that is and
when he hits you explosive and he's
explosive and he's 25 years old ladies
and gentlemen so now now you're talking
about Nate Diaz Nate Diaz is a volume
puncher but Nate Diaz doesn't have a lot
of leg and ass he's older
he's very he's an accurate puncher but
yeah so so I think someone like someone
who's as big as Jake Can bull hit Rush
his way in there take whatever shots
Nate gets gives him you're talking about
boxing now we're not talking about Ms no
so you can take those shots you really
can't from Nate you can take those shots
and Nate and then what happens is what
are you going to do when Jake puts his
head down and starts throwing with
everything he's got which he's going to
do you're gonna in eight rounds you're
gonna you're gonna there's gonna be an
opening now here's who I want to see him
but let me before you say that Rebecca
Nate let me ask you this if you had to
tell me this uh be who has better
movement who's more fluid with head work
Anderson Silva or an ideas Anderson 100
Silva correct now he landed on Silva
here's the thing too yes so for Nate
that's three rounds right God dang I
know I can't believe you're talking like
this I know that but that's kudos to
Jake but I don't I see again I love Nate
so I want the money for him but I don't
want to see Nate get hurt because I
don't think Nate has anything to prove
Nate is a guy we all want to see but I I
am not as hungry to see this fight
anymore with Nate oh I am I actually
want to see I want to see now I own
there I have mixed numbers so here
here's the how I feel about Jake I don't
want Jake to I I I I think it's unfair
for everybody to go now let's see him
fight Canada Golovkin you know or
something that's so stupid I don't want
to see that there's a balancing act here
he's so entertaining he's doing the
impossible but I don't want to see the
guy get hurt and I don't want to see the
guy fight somebody who's he's not quite
ready for but also why would he do that
so let's let's say Jake's your son be
and Jake comes up and goes hey Dad I
mean a lot of [ __ ] online dude for
fighting these older Legends should I
fight a Canelo and you can go absolutely
well you'd go
um okay just financially how much you
make in fighting the woodleys and the
askgans and the all the Andersons and
you go you know I'll probably make 20
million after the last five years okay
now if you've had a real boxer let's say
it's not canel let's just say you fight
a boxer's 10-0 who doesn't have anywhere
near the draw power and puts a more
dangerous fight how much you make you
know it's just me predicate off my paper
you buys maybe three million four
million go why would you do that so this
is the internet this is exactly what I'm
saying I would have to have a
conversation with Nate and say I mean
with Jake and say hey hey look man
you're so exciting to watch and you're
fighting these guys and we're all
interested
how serious are you about being an
actual boxer that takes this all the way
through your 30s is that worth the head
trauma is it worth actually getting in
with guys who where that's the only
thing they have he said it's not he said
because he's smart yeah because he's
[ __ ] smart he doesn't make too many
to go down that road it's like oh it's
like Jake if you really want to do this
you tell me you go to the regional
circuit you know start coming up let me
ask you a question
how would you feel about him fighting
don't don't give me a stupid name Roy
Jones Jr
um
intriguing it's not though because now
listen don't listen don't listen the
noise on the internet right because you
don't they're stupid don't listen to
that noise it's not real but if you want
to toss gasoline on that fight a 55 year
old boy Jones who's his last fight got
absolutely annihilated in Russia yeah
don't do that it's too much all right
hey hey 46 past 46 dude we're gonna say
I'm with you keeping people making money
we gotta draw the line somewhere 53 yeah
a little old I mean come on dude we've
checked that box okay I don't see him
fight Mike Tyson I don't see any of that
I got you the next step is Nate Diaz
they're the Connor keep beating up the
UFC guys that have that are more famous
than any boxer that they can give you uh
so yeah nobody's on TuneIn him how would
uh your uh hold on I've done against uh
Jake
he got knocked out
you're just being honest I know and I
like your Island you know that it's just
the real the Uriah Hall that I saw fight
Le'Veon Bell
I learned more about Le'Veon Bell right
and with you at Hall he retired from UFC
I think this was a money play and he's
trying to find himself he's talked about
you know depression you know kill
himself stuff like that so a little bit
Yeah so a little lost I think you know
so the Le'Veon Bell give him something
to do and you know it's not like you
showed out there and that was four
rounds against Le'Veon Bell what do you
think Jake would do against Le'Veon Bell
he'd beat both of them up yeah it's just
what it is okay so but with that would
that Dawson is in Jake's Corner he's got
really good boxes yeah my thing is would
that satisfy the masses out there if he
fought a Uriah so it's like for Jake the
juice has to be worth the squeeze here's
what I think Jake here's what I want to
see here's what we all want to see we
want to see Jake fight somebody his age
or a little like in their 30s who's
still got a lot of like a but my here's
my name somebody go now now but in this
I deal with this all the time people
tell I want to see him fight insert Curt
you've
hold on insert any UFC fighter it does
not work that way they're under contract
it's not even up for [ __ ] debate
leave get out of here yeah I mean the
only guy I mean I'm going to be honest
with you too I'm gonna say this too like
if all if somehow you made the Conor
McGregor thing work with him I think
counter's too small for him
I do I mean not right I've seen Connor
right now no I've seen him when he said
when that guy asked him and he goes I'm
265. color is huge right now I'm with
you well but let's say they fought at I
don't know I don't know what are they
gonna fight at well Jake's [ __ ] big
Connor is Connor's frame is still much
smaller and by the way when he's that
bulked my friend that's that's not
that's slower that's not the Conor's
Technique No I will say let you know
we're both drinking the Jake uh Paul
Kool-Aid right now I'm I'm drunk but I'm
with you
will be hard he does I'll be very clear
though don't get it twisted yeah as far
as striking goes Conor is a much better
Striker so is Anderson yeah in MMA the
sport MMA he's jacked right there and
still lean but the thing is
Connor's the worst matchup for him
now I don't I don't know if Conor beats
him but I'm out of Nate Diaz Roy Jones
all these guys you keep listening URI
Hall Conor is the worst we'll give him
the most threats he'll give us toughest
I can hit if he takes it still hard to
hit he's a master in his distance and
stuff like that but again size an issue
there but it's still and again I'm not
saying he beats on what I'm saying
though it's his toughest matchup don't
get twisted how we tend to forget how
talented Connor he's very talented to
forget because he's doing this stuff we
also forget that Jake is naturally much
bigger and can can can can crowd Conor
and start throwing man
but I'll tell you this right now again I
love all the guys he fought been asking
Woodley Anderson Silva nobody's ideas
nobody hits like Connor
now
can I tell you and I know what you I
know what you say size and all that yeah
this is why because Connor's a counter
Striker I understand so when Jake comes
in the timing and speed of Conor is
second to we've never seen somebody
better at in sports history as far as
UFC fighting goes doesn't happen really
that's what made him so special aren't
the guys he was fighting 145 pounds
really small people though Nate was 170.
not too much that's didn't knock him out
though to your point that's a good
argument and he had a small small gloves
and Nate was like got back up and he was
all those gloves ain't [ __ ] though those
talents clubs they don't really make a
difference yeah it's more for protection
I mean I I'm just saying but to your
point yeah
gun to the head it's like and I'm if
there's one person I Love More Than Jake
it's con Conor's my guy I'm gonna tell
you how that fight but but I'm telling
you
that fight would end up this way Connor
would put like Conor be hard to hit he'd
be given business early on you think and
then what would happen is that that
[ __ ] big kid that big he's gonna land
farm boy would be hanging on you and
you'd get tired and Conor's not known
for his amazing cardio Jake's not a
hanger he doesn't have the experience
yet well thank you but he just just
getting him just move bullying you into
the punches to the bodies rip into the
body by the way he was hitting uh
Anderson
big body shots and Connor doesn't have
that broke his nose oh dude and you get
started getting hit in the ribs or in
your elbows like that with those body
shots where he's just like boom boom huh
it's been tough to do again together I
don't know not not when you get him in
the corner it's very rare Conor loses
striking matches and he loses grappling
in the beginning but if we have an
eight-round fight there's enough time
for him to land those shots no again I'm
again I'm not saying Conor's beat him
I'm just saying out of the options
you're giving me yeah Conor's the
toughest matchup skill wise timing yeah
his distance
Jake's calling Canelo out
can you explain that to me well you got
to remember the world he comes from that
trolling job like trolls too yeah that's
what these kids do yeah it's just to get
you fired up and because think about it
you say oh this is fixed right the
narrative the internet they don't know
anything about fighting what do you mean
fix it's so stupid what are you talking
about but but I was saying this on the
shop explaining to Mark and chin and
Casey in there
but I think it it gives credit to Jake
when people say it's fixed because what
he's doing is so insane that the only
way you can handle it when your life is
going that's fake that's exactly I was
thinking that too you know when you see
someone on Instagram do something insane
and yeah dude it's 10 or Mark like this
is fake it's like but it when we realize
it's not fake like oh that guy that
guy's a freak because what Jake is doing
is it's never gonna happen again it's so
insane
that we think is fake so this right here
right this guy posted this goes oh
you're telling me it's not rigged so
look at this so again that's probably
doctored I'd go on the limb and say
that's [ __ ] doctor of course but then
remember this confirmation bias so I
would be willing to bet that guy went
through 30 takes until he clearly got
something that doesn't look like a punch
but then look at this one
you tell me if this is fixed tell me if
this fixed me you tell me where it's
fixed so punch there
clearly doctored but again chin chose
that video has three million views and
it's just came out so by tomorrow
probably six months the problem is most
people probably didn't watch the fight
they think that's real oh this guy
pulled it from Showtime it's not real
it's doctored but it creates this this
narrative that it's fit there are a
couple things that go on with a guy like
Jake and for that matter Sean O'Malley
when you do [ __ ] when you beat the
number one guy or when you are Jake Paul
and and you're a YouTuber and you're
flashy but you work that hard and you
improve that much in two and a half
years and you're still allowed people
hate it and then you prove that and your
girl looks like that think about think
about the balls it takes to get in with
Anderson Silva think about the balls
because oh he knows how he did against
to Julio Travis Jr yeah a real boxer a
real badass former world champion he
knows so so then he gets in there and
does the impossible and knocks him out
shows he's got he can take a punch shows
he can box shows he can hit like a
[ __ ] all that stuff he has
cardio the only thing you can do because
what he does is and I we all feel this
way you go you go two things happen you
go I'm lazy as [ __ ] I'm a lazy it's
trigger I'm not I'm not brave the way he
is and I gotta get off my ass but or you
do that and you maybe get motivated and
go it that inspired me some people start
writing that it doesn't inspire me but
some people go I get off my ass other
people go oh I'm gonna try and drag this
guy down so to my unhappiness it's not
fair he's doing if you do that you're
just good luck with that philosophy
here's the problem it doesn't work guys
I know you're if you're anybody who's
listening is Young if you do that and
you br and you and you actually decide
to try to take someone down like Jay
Paul it's a terrible anyone for that
matter it's a terrible philosophy and
practice for you it will get you nothing
but exactly zero less than zero I
promise but also celebrated but also
those guys that you hate on you know I
get my fair share hey those guys you
hate on whether it's Drake Machine Gun
Kelly Machine Gun Kelly made a shirt
that says the Internet isn't real so
Machine Gun Kelly gets so much hate
right so if you if you're just live you
know you're addicted to your cell phone
you're like God people hate Machine Gun
Kelly but if you open up your eyes and
you look at how many downloads he has on
Spotify if you look at his Arena you
ever see how much how many tickets he
sells that's what I'm saying Arena sold
out tour or Drake for that matter
whoever whoever is whoever it is doing
okay yeah okay oh or even me oh dude his
comedy's not
but I heard I heard that they wanted to
add another show like a third show two
shows yeah but I heard they wanted to
add I heard they were standing room only
yeah but so it's like the the it also
doesn't work dude
you're not so wasting your time I think
that if you if you if you spend that
much time hating just for anybody who's
young and like it it just and I've done
it look I'm guilty of it we're all
guilty of it but the thing is like when
I speak as a man at this age and I and I
talk to young people who are doing
things that aren't working uh I'll just
give you a quick example like I did
everything that anybody's doing I I've
been a hater I've been it's very easy
no no I didn't but in my heart I'm like
in my heart everything that those people
feel yeah I'm like I [ __ ] you know
but why them it doesn't help you like
when I was in acting class and I used to
sit back and criticize I had a teacher
look at me and go he was a famous very
good actor Jeffrey Tambor yeah and he
said uh he looked at me and he said
you've done credit sizing up there are
you going to put something on here
because the same critic is going to come
back to you when you try so these people
are actually trying and you're up there
acting like you've figured out acting
good luck you know and anytime you do
anything like that I I was at I was in
therapy I was in couples therapy and I
was like I would come at him with this
Warrior energy if somebody [ __ ] with me
I'd say this stuff and he goes like this
he goes boy you're really comfortable
with that Warrior energy I go yeah man
that's how I am I live my life you know
what he said to me and there's a guy I
wrestle at ASU and he's a great great
therapist yeah like a what a [ __ ] I mean
a real tough guy a real man but also
I've been practicing therapy for a while
yeah I had gone through his own thing
you know what it was I I this sounds so
weird and he goes he goes you know what
the problem with that Warrior stuff that
you do that threatening stuff I go what
he goes doesn't work no I said tough
guys but it's stopped me because
whatever you're after that doesn't work
and if you treat people like that and
talk to people like that they they just
go that's cool they smile they log it
away dude and so
did they I think it's better to look at
what what do you want in your life and
then what is going to work but that [ __ ]
doesn't work no and if you're and if you
do the right thing you'll you'll the
world will open up it'll be around
people that you admire yeah yeah like I
love being inspired by people I like
that you're three and see what Jake does
next so so but wait so dream fight for
Jake because I'm not as interested in
the in Nate well this out this out next
yes
bigger
no no for a variety of reasons okay
that'd be easier okay hold on let me
think uh give me a this well I'll tell
you how it's gonna go he's gonna fight
Nate next Nate being at that fights now
he's going to fight it's all
predetermined yeah yeah he'll fight Nate
next I bet they announce in the next
month or two years in like March so you
get Nate and then I think Jay depending
what he wants to do you know the
canelo's talk and who you know whoever
else real box you call out it's never
gonna happen I think he rides off in the
sunset and Logan Paul talked about this
on fight campaign where uh Logan I'm
sorry uh food truck diary I think Logan
Paul and Jake Paul is his last fight oh
come on yeah really it's the biggest
payday but Logan's not boxing he's doing
www no Logan's boxing he's fighting KSI
next oh wow and Logan uh just called out
Andrew Tate he wants to he's still
boxing because think about two brothers
fighting even though they promised their
parents they wouldn't that's a huge
fight and they're both with their fan
bases Andrew Tate's no joke but he's got
eye problems I think uh yeah Logan have
his hands full there I don't like that
but I'm like his background entertain is
a kickboxer it's a little bit different
isn't it compared to a YouTuber though
and he's not Jake no he's not training
it tastes pretty big how big is the
entertainment Andrew Tate World Champ
man uh yeah I guess it's 6364. that's a
big guy six three that's a big fella 198
pounds that's a big that's a cruiser
right I mean Logan's nuts black heavy
Logan's not small Kitty no no but that's
that's that's a big man who can put it
on you there's a similar size yeah
that's a that's a that's a strong fella
but yeah it's not as great uh call out
yeah Logan's not small
I think he's sixth yeah Logan's big boy
um so you could do it for Logan like
that but again Logan and Jake are on two
different two different paths yeah and
you think they fight and then they ride
off into the sunset yep that's what I
think
I mean he's ever been as tall as you are
both
I mean he's a little taller than you are
he's six four
he's up there am I wrong he's definitely
taller than six two he's 100 yeah he's a
big kid he's he's I stood next to him
he's [ __ ] every bit of look at how
long his legs are he's a big guy yeah
easy on the eyes the kid too yeah it's
interesting
wow
um so yeah I think they I don't know how
much longer Jake's gonna do it but you
have those do you think you have the
dates you have the Nate fights maybe the
Conor and then but I think his last
fight's gonna be against Logan and then
she does what the hell he's gonna have
all the money all the money here's the
biggest podcast in the world too yeah
it's so crazy Jake does you don't think
you don't think that Jake uh doesn't
touch Canelo that's never happening
that's just stupid talking yeah no not
Canada love can no no no no no no no no
no no no no it'd be a terrible idea yeah
to what though terrible idea because
also Gennady is not as big you know as
as far as the name power goes so well
but but but Jake has that thing in him
that he wants to really challenge
himself I don't think so not yet but
he's not stupid everything's calculated
yeah someone's like Triple G are you out
of your [ __ ] that's about his Camp
would be like hey hey wait a minute hold
on no no that's a little crazy that's
not and you don't want to come on his
six fights insane no that's insane I
don't even think I don't even think he
can get it I'm sanctioned I mean he gets
ancient but you don't want to you don't
want to do it that doesn't make sense no
no no it's a disaster because
well I guess I guess but even Gennady is
40 so then even if you beat him which he
wouldn't but if he did then people are
just like oh just be an old Triple G
yeah so that's all you get but he's not
the triple G's he just seems to just
tune out everything and just keep doing
what he's doing making all the money in
the world beating up these older guys
yeah that's all he needs to do yeah and
then and right after the sunset fighting
your brother you get Nate Connor Logan
that's well over 100 million for a total
for those fights and then I don't know
what you do have babies with that
ridiculously hot girlfriend you have and
I live in Puerto Rico where the hell
they're at
not a bad gig no
he's doing it he's the American dream
yeah I don't know if we'll ever see
something like him again
yeah you will
but look at that
look at that
amazing yeah I think there and I think
Jake's gonna do some WWE stuff too
yeah man
amazing I still yeah I love it I love it
and I definitely don't want to see him
get hurt well okay
yeah what are you gonna do
she's uh was that an 11 or a 12 what
would you say that's the 13 right down
there yeah so she's at Denver 13. you
move her into your house and you don't
even know her she doesn't have to speak
English she just go would you like to
move into my house and there it is
yeah life not does not suck for that guy
and that's why it'd be worse so mad at
him he works for it yeah he really does
yeah now can we talk about yep no
private jets yep now Fury doesn't want
um Fury Tyson Fury doesn't want any of
that dude how about this he couldn't
find a better looking girl than that
go to that person's profile please
because she's well zero followers that's
not real it's real that's not real
that's a Russian box
that's all dude how about Elon buying
Twitter elon's so [ __ ] funny he's
like us if we were billionaires because
do you see Jeff Bezos talk [ __ ] about
him and he obviously can't buy it
because don't make me buy Amazon you
just respond back don't make me buy
Amazon
what did you ever say like hating on him
you know I can't believe he's doing this
he goes don't make me buy Amazon the
problem is that's so funny that that is
a big buy but the problem is it's a
terrible terrible deal it's got to
figure out how to make it profitable
either way he wins because remember how
much he's worth so so the 44 billion
isn't doesn't really affect his
lifestyle in any facet and now you know
uh Tesla and he said this years ago he
said Tesla would be worth 700 billion it
was late uh just it went down a little
bit but uh
probably four months ago's uh recorded
at one trillion dollars so he's not
worried you know
no no
no you remember how people are skeptical
he didn't have the money to buy Twitter
all these billionaires hating on them
excuse me yeah okay I'll buy it it's
gonna be interesting to see what uh
what goes on now because you know there
I mean who was it who this publishing
house
um uh there was a guy who they didn't
they wrote an open letter saying that
Amy call me Barrett who's a Supreme
Court Justice she wrote a book and uh I
think it was random house or someone
wrote an open letter all the all the
people saying we don't want to publish
this book because she voted against Roe
v Wade which what she did is said it's
not a it's a state issue it's not a
constitutional issue it's not
constitutional
and it's it's funny that you have
Publishers now Publishers and it's their
right to decide what they want to
publish or not but based on political
points should you get another publisher
yeah I just don't think I just think
it's a bad idea to have Publishers
deciding the same thing with Woody
Allen's Memoir he's there's never been
any proof it's just one person that says
something and they they [ __ ] refused
to they took his Memoirs down
it's like wow man he married his
stepdaughter right no it's because
it's when she was seven or yeah you know
yeah but I mean man the stepdaughter's
weird however you go about it but it's
like that's not illegal it's weird it's
creepy because his wife Mia Farrow his
ex-wife said he molested their daughter
no the daughter said it too right but
then there's no two investigations zero
evidence never the only accusation never
happened before it's just an and oh by
the way Mia Farrow her team with Alan
dershowitz said give us eight million
dollars and we won't we'll keep it quiet
[ __ ] off yeah his own and Mia Farrow who
adopted 11 kids three of those children
have committed suicide and one of us has
accused her of abuse
interesting yeah so you know but I mean
yeah for Elon it's weird right because
he uh right when he buys Twitter he
walks in the headquarters uh with the
sink and that just that lady's face when
he he was like gather around he's like
firing him
yeah I didn't know that I didn't know oh
there's pictures of shoes like the CFO
and she was like one of the main [ __ ]
talkers her face now granted she got
like 50 million dollar buyout yeah well
because her face her face is like this
and he was like you're [ __ ] out of
here dude oh my God let me see this
chin sink let's start with the kitchen
Twitter reviewed by Bloomberg that musk
is going to be walking around the
corridors of this office staff are being
encouraged to say hello to them uh to
him when they see Elon Musk and we're
told he will address staff on Friday as
you said in the top of the show The
Washington Post and Bloomberg both
reporting last week that musk was
telling potential Equity investors in
this deal that he would cut head count
by as much as 75 as I've reported it
let's get rid of everybody right now at
Twitter a new piece of news we're being
reported by Bloomberg according to
sources some Equity investors not on the
debt side but the equity side have
already transferred their committed
Capital to must lawyers so it looks like
all signs were moving towards this deal
closing by 5 PM Eastern and and did you
see uh some some uh companies who
advertise on you know several million
dollars a lot of companies go uh Elon if
if you allow Trump to get back on we're
not going to advertise anymore the
problem problem is with most people can
do that problem is when you're worth
whatever is 100 billion dollars 200
billion dollars he goes okay okay okay
and you took company private he goes
okay
let's get other ones well also you gotta
remember people make money on Twitter
um with it with by advertising things so
they'll they actually put out the ads on
it and right now Twitter takes none of
that money so there's a way to monetize
Twitter you can get one percent well
have you heard well have you heard what
what this what the rumor I heard is
people that verified you're gonna have
to pay for that verification a so it
keeps a lot of bots out I think that's
why he's doing but to get incentive to
get paid it's a good idea too yeah I'm
not mad I don't I think it's ten dollars
but also anytime you want to advertise
on Twitter and you have like an account
that you are getting paid to advertise
on they'll get they'll get a piece of it
and right now they don't take it but you
see Elon had to take his tweet down he
messed up it I you know I agree with
people honestly messed up because the
Pelosi thing right where there's this
narrative going on on online against
with some credible people that think it
was a leveler's quarrel and this is
insane they both had I heard about this
this morning and there's a disagreement
against pay right and is there anything
in the mainstream media about no they
can't because they can't right now but
they said they're waiting on the body
cam footage right and yeah so it should
get interesting they were both in their
underwear yeah both of them were two
hammers I'm not talking about the
Hammers in the pants I'm talking it's so
embarrassing the whole thing is so
embarrassing and then apparently broke
in but here's the problem with that
someone took a picture from the sky
right and they I'm assume they just
panicked and they broke the glass from
the inside out and so some detective on
Twitter gets on there takes the picture
that shows that there's a robbery you
know break in and they're trying to kill
Nancy Pelosi which isn't true uh broke
the glass and he goes I've been so funny
this guy has no skin the games I'm a
detective 40 years I've seen house
robberies never once in my 40 year
history have I seen somebody breaking
the house and the glass goes outside so
he's inside just physically and he goes
just saying so there's some skeptical
hippo eyes with all this who knows you
know who knows I know what I believe but
who knows but this is what Elon did Elon
he he goes I think there's a lot more to
this uh Nancy Pelosi's husband than than
we know and he re-posted uh this article
but that article that he posts like
Santa Monica times whatever the
notoriously known for spreading
misinformation okay so it's a not a
credible Source okay she'd been so much
better if he just didn't quote anybody
and just put that instead of adding the
article so he had to take the article
down because I think people like you're
gonna quote this and got lit up for
quoting the Santa Monica whatever so it
could be though that this is this is uh
thank you
can you go back up with it for a sec oh
was that Lindsey Pearlman television
actress found dead after being reported
missing
do you know her maybe
Maybe
who is she Lindsey Pearlman
Chicago Justice Empire damn
uh she might have taken her own life
all right
yeah no I I thought I knew her I don't
know I'm sorry anyway back to pelosia
podcast no so so so so are you but but
how uh how credible is this talk
you know if you go online you look at
the people that know you know some of
this stuff because
you know I was talking to sambad I go
Sam is it weird that CNN and fox isn't
uh like alluding to any of the skills
well those aren't real news he goes
isn't it weird that you're getting
details about the stuff from Twitter
because think about we had most of our
breaking news from Twitter he goes think
about the Jeffrey uh or uh the uh what's
his [ __ ] name the kid on uh was it
power or whatever the Jesse Smollett he
goes think about that right CNN Fox
about this is terrible you know a noose
and all this well but they did come out
and say it's not the hoax after that no
no no no not right away no not right
unlined it so Twitter did right Twitter
came and go oh I smell something fishy
here two in the morning one through
Chicago get a Subway sandwich and then
the cops show up and we've seen the
video of a new surrounding neck so a ton
of people off the bat even even uh
Kamala Harris Biden this is horrible
look at this hate crime all this stuff
without even looking into it Twitter was
the ones went we're not buying this and
then they started putting out the facts
it's kind of what's going on here
so remember the way Fox and CNN works
and Sam made a great point off here same
goes those aren't legit news sources
anymore
he's a friend let him in there's
something about that yeah according uh
yeah according because this is where I
have skeptical hip-hop are you saying
that this is where the skeptical hippo
has come in so
this guy who if you read these official
accounts from Fox and Newark post and
CNN all major Outlets this this Vagabond
this guy who is homeless and spreading
all these uh conspiracy theories stuff
like that who's homeless and was making
bracelets
Nancy Pelosi her house in San Francisco
I don't know if you've seen it right
Pelosi and depop were both holding a
hammer with one hand and Bap had his
other hand holding onto Pelosi's form
and he also didn't hit him to the cops
well he greeted the officers I want to
be figure this to figure this out for me
so this this man who according to all
the reports that we've heard is homeless
right uh doesn't have a job was living
like in some van I guess at one point
and creating bracelets this madman
and we've seen what he looks like right
now exactly a physical specimen you're
telling me in Nazi place by Third in
power most powerful and probably more
powerful than Biden
it has all the security there that
governments they're pretty good right
you're telling this guy jumped over the
fact well no no there is there so if you
are the spouse of a sitting Congress
person or Senator you do not have uh
this is where you gotta run you just
gotta run Nancy came out and goes what's
bothering to me is when I leave town we
actually up the security for my husband
there's more security private security
then yes because they have a lot of
money yes well what do you mean a lot of
money all the money be wait hold on to
say that he was going to hold Nancy
houses and talk to her if Nancy were to
tell to Pat the truth he would let her
go if she lied it's going to break her
kneecaps okay
um
well I just think it's interesting so we
know that when the cops came both of
them are holding hammers
now why were they both in the underwear
though I don't know I guess the man I
didn't see that they were both in their
underwear well I guess the man the the
Nancy Pelosi's husband it's I guess
early in the morning or I'm saying at 2
A.M he comes down right why is the other
guy in their underwear
uh where's the body cam yeah affidavit
further debunks conspiracy promoted by
Elon Musk the federal charge until
Monday also for the debunk a conspiracy
theory about the policy attack that was
previously on Twitter Twitter by
billionaire owner Elon Musk conspiracy
claimed that among other things that
Paul Pelosi knew his attacker must
tweeted a link to an Arco promoting the
theory on Sunday uh unsealed Monday
alongside the federal shots it says
Pelosi still told the 9 11 dispatch
return oh so that makes it not know who
the man yeah so so our information oh it
is FBI affidavit well no but the
affidavit is going based off the call
from Nancy Pelosi's husband going I
don't know him
but then we're also hearing you've never
seen David before
uh didn't know the suspect yeah that's
correct yeah that's cool I mean how do
you get in B explain it to me and why
was the glass on the outside not the
inside is that why is it two in the
morning look that up let me see if they
can get up on the outside of the inside
why would I make it up because I feel
like you're you're a little bit of a
rumor mill right now I want it to be
true because I'm so titillated oh this
is Jesse small at part two that's isn't
it weird the timing of it so you are you
tell me the Dems are getting their ass
whooped in the midterm well you know
Rogan said that the the elections on
Tuesday is going to be like in the The
Shining when the elevator opens and just
the hallways is full of blood
um
but there's glass on the inside
that looks like it came it went in that
way oh yeah but the and then the window
would the glass would hang on the
outside like that because that looks
like you somebody hidden from the end
from the outside I don't know I'm not an
expert on glass breakage but it sounds
to me like that looks to me like
I mean there would be glass
that'd be glass on the ground
a ton of Glass on the ground Outside
Inside yeah yeah it's interesting now
this this guy but this guy who's Crazy
says we can kill Nancy he got through
security jumped the backyard and he just
broke the window no alarm nothing 2 am
uh you know why are they in the
underwear we had a whole apparently he
had a whole like uh wasn't he talking
anti-semitic stuff and all kinds of
crazy [ __ ] online mm-hmm
yep you're you're you still got
skeptical hippo you believe all that
from Fox and CNN I just I just I I'm
looking at what the FBI affidavit said
there'd have to be something to did you
know him did you make a call did he come
to your house I mean he did break the
window was it a Lover's spat did he make
the window
or or did Pelosi's husband say he's a
friend let him in
you're telling me that guy was able to
avoid all that security and break in
there's no there's no security on the
window we know he said he's a friend let
him in who's that again I don't know
he's spreading rumors Now That's What I
Hear You rumor guy you know what I hear
I hear the guy who did this Paul depap I
mean to Pap whatever his name is
gonna fight Jake Paul next that's what I
heard when he gets out of prison so
isn't that interesting
and the only thing that adds to this too
is uh you know Nancy Pelosi's husband
got a DUI a few months ago right I do
now you know there's two people in the
car right two airbags went off sir now
you know no hold on let me just talk
Common Sense okay but I'm not spreading
anything
you know two airbags went up the airbags
would go off yeah they'd go out because
you have to have a human body over a
certain weight in order for that
passenger seat airbag to go off is that
true only way it works it won't go off
it's the only way it works it's not
activate if there's not enough I need
some I need to see some evidence that's
why when you sit in a car you will see a
green light that says airbag detected
uh-huh
find that for me I'm looking because
you're you're saying a lot of stuff here
you're saying a lot of words bro
and you're talking about the husband of
a sitting
government official all you talking
about it does inside trading he would
never do this I'm just saying oh you're
talking about the guy who's married to
the lady who has a better batting
average with the stock market than
Warren Buffett Brian this tracks
I mean there's a picture I just see it
on one side Bubba no no that's what are
you talking about that looks like it's
closer to yeah that's that's
it's not one giant airbag it's each
compartment
and he's only one way to go I need a
better look
at the car above you got messed up
like gaming it looks good for uh
go for again 82 what for 18 years that
looks pretty good that's handsome by the
way yeah now are you suggesting that he
he dabbles in uh well see I only see it
on the right driver's side bubble oh see
there's something here that other side
one yeah like a side one so there's the
driver one it comes out there the other
one comes out through the dash
yo this one's popped this one's popped
okay I have the I have the same car I
know how it goes well you get a
notification if for that you want him to
be gay very badly you want you want a
man to have been in there oh no that's
not for debate they're gay man I mean
this is hey hold on yeah no hey hold on
bro what you can't just start throwing
that around we don't know yet nothing
wrong with it I'm not saying there is I
don't care you can't just say that he's
gay you know what I'm not wrong with it
you can't just say that the speaker of
the house is the husband is a gay man
they've been married a long time yes sir
and I mean does he look at Nancy's big
tits and go oh sure
I mean I don't know
I I personally find Nancy Pelosi I think
she's a very attractive woman that's
what I'm saying yeah
that was the joke I I liked her when she
was like uh she's like I'm gonna punch
him I'm gonna punch him in the face I'm
gonna go to jail I'm Gonna Be Happy
she's a she's a tough one she's a tough
one she's intelligent I would have uh
100 dated her when she was younger
because you know she was built well I
don't know what that picture was
go up and go another I did this one
earlier yeah maybe that one [ __ ] those
sweater puppies back there yeah it's a
bad bad picture get go up to the right
baby do me a favor
yeah no she's cool too in person
her politics are very different than
mine but she's attractive and
intelligent
that's all I'll say
yeah
I mean I guess yeah I don't know
just some hitters on her though man why
does everybody say that stop saying that
big sweater hitters
my god let's not get crazy here man
she's so well taking care of woman that
she takes care of herself yeah kid's
blood uh what were you saying what what
come on dude I don't like Brian's like
man look how gorgeous I'm just saying
she's 90. yeah she's she's an older
woman 70s she's 80. I'm very respectful
of anybody who's that age who survived
regardless 82 years old so I'm always
going to be respectful
always children Biden just doing the
damn thing got a lot of old people Diane
Feinstein's 89 holy [ __ ] we got to get
some young people in there
but listen if they're still doing it my
dad's sharp as a [ __ ] tack so he's
82. I'll get him out of there though
shut up yeah get him out he had a fine
stand out his full dementia
I mean like people were reporting yeah
I think after 70 get him out of it or
something
there's some outlier
yeah but think about their the their
view of the world ton of wisdom right so
that's what I have you as on the board
right sometimes you want people who keep
us grounded and say hey guys the wind's
blowing and you guys are going all the
way over here we've been here before
remember no doubt who is that Brian well
it depends on who you're looking at but
they're not Nancy Pelosi yeah she's
going the wind's blown over here blow it
harder over here yeah let's ruin every
city well my my thing is like Pelosi and
Biden for a lot of their career were
fairly middle of the road they were like
sort of conservative Democrats and it
feels like they've been hijacked by this
far left insanity Choice it's like Jimmy
Kimmel right now right in front of Elon
Musk it's like bro you're on the man
show I'm taking front of you oh big time
he is he's like he's like man I used to
respect you you know you're a real piece
of [ __ ] spreading this information about
Pelosi's husband what I think happened
is because you know he's on network TV
tonight's show
I think you know he's done a lot of
stuff the the blackface Karl Malone and
he was on the man show like he went hard
in the paint so I think the laugh's like
hey [ __ ] you hear me a mouthpiece for
us or we're going to point The Smoking
Gun at you he's like say less Elon piece
of [ __ ] you know that's what I think's
going on
made a deal with the devil well that
Devil's far left can be very interesting
to see what happens on Tuesday
oh yeah I'm not even mine I can't
predict the future but I I mean we know
how that's going to go yeah yeah
what
you want to go to India no okay for what
let's go to an ashram go to Bombay
go see what do we do
it's
probably the most colorful place on the
planet no I get that I like colors what
would we do we would just go and
document an experience how long
six days Oh no I got two days two days
for you that's it that's two days just
two days oh yeah it was six to play grab
accident in India
yeah but it might be an amazing
experience
maybe even line up a couple shows in
India I I don't know he's the one torn
out in India
oh yeah I hope we have a fan base I have
family there I have people but friends
of my parents 16 hours
30 years straight you wanna get sixty
dollars to eat some food and look at
colorful things but it's India I know it
would be nice magical yeah would be nice
I mean I get on those scooters
heard they're dangerous yeah you go you
go you go to Mumbai and it's you go
everywhere I usually have five dollars
you're like Elon Musk out there well
it's it's a lot cheaper than most places
but it's um India is is becoming a
superpower India in many ways is
becoming one of the focus and look at
that slum
but but that's a whole thriving economy
see that's why I want to stay in there
we could go there I won't sleep in there
that is a thriving economy though
they're called Untouchables but yeah
sure well no but but as as the guy who
wrote shantaram said I never saw so many
Smiles I never counted so many Smiles in
Oh you mean it's thriving in their
positivity yes because living those
Shacks they're not easy right yeah not
easy but
there's more Smiles there for sure there
are in a western country yeah we're all
chasing something not easy oh yeah let's
go there Brian
get some perspective yes I think in a
lot of ways we would come back with much
more than we left with
I said it out loud you don't like my
attitude about about obviously how do I
fight you right now I will fight you at
your piece of [ __ ] I'm just you're a
piece of [ __ ] all I'm saying oh you're
too wishy-washy two in the middle it
drives me nuts no you're two in the
middle are you are you doing magic mind
because you have you have aggression I
always do a match of fun hey it's made
how many are you doing seven hey no all
right two just two two that's it here's
the thing about magic mine yeah make
your boy aggressive I know it does I
know I think it's different that magic
mind gets you going no there's no stairs
in it he's got now the magic mind for
apparently he told me he sent we get
some he's sending it here I said hey no
you send me to my house send me some
[ __ ] he said he sent uh he said he said
okay
but uh now they have this they they have
they have the only energy drink to do
this they have I guess the beads in it
it's a Time release thing so so the way
you don't have time released it's like
these beads that digest take forever to
digest yes and it's just so you'll have
initial shot and then it just works
throughout the Adderall like that too
yeah there's Adderall yeah the magic
mine's fantastic I know I'm obsessed me
too I see it every day I know I knew I
told you I knew I knew when no but with
the Nancy's with the plus stuff I'll
fight you no matter what magic man or
not dude I don't like your attitude I
just think that the story you're telling
about her husband being gay that's not
my story okay but I'm just saying it no
no that's that's that's water cooler
talk that's not you got me excited and I
was excited that that was a oh sorry oh
and it's not true because chin brought
up CNN as Eddie Bravo says where do you
get your news I wanted the FBI I want to
get evidence if this is true I'm very
excited about hold on hold on the FBI
you're talking about the people that
suppress the information on Hunter Biden
and the laptop hear that FBI I will
fight you here's what's your word here's
what I find very interesting they're
both using a hammer one he's holding on
to his a thing and he goes they're both
in another word yeah and he goes how you
doing and then he hits Pelosi in the
head yep that's interesting so they
might have been in a fight how did
Pelosi have time to call when he's 82
and he was being tied up no that's all
tracks dude
there is fishy [ __ ] going on
why are they both also why though yeah
does it sound like there's maybe a
dispute over payment for [ __ ] done
eating there's a dispute over payment
guys rich why would he have a problem
what maybe he'll let old Nance you know
how much I'm forking out maybe he says
maybe this is here's a scenario maybe
they have they [ __ ] and the guy goes hey
uh you got to give me some money or I'm
gonna keep my voice down or I'm gonna
start talking yeah you know what let's
wait till your wife comes home give me
give me a million dollars where's Nancy
at that's where that's Nancy and then
he's like this guy's trying to kill me
now they said to use code word to alert
the Police that he was being taken
hostage or whatever yeah and the the
dispatch knows that the dispatch knew
the code word
yeah they would usually know the code
word yeah
but why was he act why was he given
access to his phone how did he do that
if they were fighting how does that
everybody hide out that's what everybody
does when you want to take over somebody
one of the most powerful people's house
in the world you want to give the guy
time to make a phone call is there
anything about David to Pap about being
a hooker
get your time I gave her pay yeah
I mean you do this little thing about
fine kid we get down to the nitty-gritty
we are breaking news here
I don't see anything Bubba
I mean wait hold on you don't see
anything on CNBC you don't see anything
on CNN you'll see anything on ABC
I mean
the past have been drifting further into
the world of far-right conspiracies and
some of them hate according to Times
review of his online accounts in a
personal Blog the department posts
include such topics as manipulation of
History Holo Hawks and it's okay to be
white he mentioned 4chan a favorite
Message Board of the far right he posted
videos about conspiracies involvement
cover 19c but this doesn't mean he would
attack
um no it adds to them to your theory but
also I'm not saying this guy's not
batshit crazy right
but it also could mean he made his money
by being a uh an escort it could also
mean that
you know what I mean oh yeah
um
and maybe
they did know each other
hold on
a number of conservative online yeah I
just need all my facts you know because
right now I'm they're making them very
very yeah they're making them seem like
a extreme far right yeah yeah yeah why
would they do that before midterms I
don't get it
yeah I don't know it's like they're
losing right it's interesting I know man
I grew up in British Columbia that
explains it
um oh dude oh he made money being a hemp
jewelry maker he was described as a
father was mentioned in San Francisco
Chronicle article I was described as the
father figure of gypsy towel but nudist
who lived in a three-bedroom Victorian
apartment in Berkeley with her then
fiance and her three children
he was a hemp jewelry maker and he was
the best man at tab's wedding
I didn't care I don't know dude
I don't know no you guys bad [ __ ] crazy
yeah doesn't mean you're not like wiener
in his mouth that's the thing you know
what this is he had to make a living and
you know it's doing to you and I love
watching this in real time yeah
see you see what you're doing now and
now you're gonna leave here and go God
that crazy guy I'm just saying that you
know what this is distracted one smoke
I'm looking for one little piece of
evidence so far my evidence is Brendan
Schaub talking in my left ear right and
spreading all over it's a rumor you
ready for me to put the nail in the
coffin you know what who wrote the
circle now you tell me if what Ellie
times Prince is real okay every so
everything L.A times Prince is real to
you no why not there's some
misinformation same well with Washington
Post L.A times New York Times CNN LA
Times in MSNBC LA Times in particular in
particular yeah they have an agenda
right yeah they can really mess your
life up yeah some would say that you
will let me just put the nail in the
cuff and argument this is the LA Times
article we're reading right now oh well
then it's a lot but they're not but they
do they would never be biased no no
never no they wouldn't have an agenda
trying to ruin you far left there you go
weird
so let's bring that up chin LA Times
come on
all I'm saying and now no I'm waiting
and seeing I'm waiting me too and I'm
not saying I believe all this I'm just
saying I got some questions you're
spreading you you know you're starting
to sound like Sam tripley and Eddie
Bravo right now because you're spreading
you're just saying I have questions this
honestly on Earth is flat I ain't saying
it's round though just saying I got a
question I'm gonna say it's wrong I'm
saying it's a realm I'm saying it Sam
goes I'm not on earth flat earth guy I'm
a realm guy all right Sam oh that's it
listen I like because the the conspiracy
is better than the truth most the times
it's fun to entertain it but when Sam's
like yeah Obama you know his real
parents were this people and his wife's
uh hermaphrodite I'm just like I'm out
I'm out well that was like when you were
talking about the uh the Comsat Nate
fight backstage and raising questions
like you were [ __ ] around everybody's
like you know you're telling the truth
well because that's fun because it's
like brenshaw believes that you know
there was no conspiracy that doesn't
make happen I play around with yeah what
makes headlines in me calm [ __ ] yeah
all right go ahead give me um
here's some current events
Sherlock Holmes so the first one is a
sad one I know you guys heard about this
by now the South Korea there's a
Halloween
of course because they hit New York Post
because uh two Americans died in it
right yeah two Americans
um a bunch of a lot of young people what
happened it was just an event where they
didn't realize that there was a hundreds
of thousands of people showing up they
didn't realize that there's that many
people they had like one officer per 500
people and so people got trampled
stampede so they got squeezed to death
basically oh man that'd be a terrible
way to go yeah so I'll show you some of
this right here and sold but dozens of
others you see how packed it is there's
narrow areas too and they're there it's
like New York Times during uh New Year's
Eve um what do you call that place
Times Square covered restrictions
flooded into the narrow streets of Souls
and then you can even see there's
footage of like
tons of people that are not even like uh
Medics but doing CPR and other people
just scattered around everywhere why are
all these people there though it's they
said that since this is like the first
real get together after all the pandemic
um South Korea yeah so they want to just
go out and party I get it and that's it
one which is a very I don't know South
Korea was really the head that's been
strict up until now I mean this is
probably the first big event since the
restrictions were lifted wow you know
you know because I went to Canada and I
was a good of the vaccine all that's
gone you know it's harder for Canadians
Coming to America in regards to covid
protocols than for Americans go to
Canada because in America we still
require vaccines all right for the
foreigners not for me I don't know
anything but if you're Canadian coming
here you have to prove it yeah Canadian
board is wide open
yeah no true doors uh
Castro's kid yeah
right you don't want to argue with that
right now right right we know this right
you know you know his mom was I know
Trudeau was in the house with with
Pelosi and I know that much but you know
Trudeau his mom was on her honeymoon and
was very close friends with Fidel Castro
Rabbit Hole they look a lot alike
all right again I don't like where
you're going no I see uh but see I don't
need to argue this no I'm just stupid I
don't need to argue this it's possible
that they look alike you ever seen his
dad you ever seen his real dad yes go
ahead go ahead far right chin where you
at just one over on the right yeah oh
sorry there's there's this guy right
there yep I don't oh yeah that looks
like Trudeau or does Fidel Castro look
like him
they look a lot alike dude holy [ __ ] now
you know in 2016 he gave Fidel Castro
all the praise you know he's the only
dictator in the world that didn't shame
Fidel Castro when he passed away
it's just not tracking oh it's this is
too easy oh my God that's so awesome
foreign
he's holding him there what
Caster's holding yeah yeah maybe he's
holding another baby no no that no no
that's true though right there because
it doesn't get right it's the Sun
right that's incredible
look at that and then this isn't
conspiracy you know uh
uh uh Trudeau's parents there's openly
swingers because he was a lot older she
was 18 when they met got married at 22.
well it's you know Castro was a stud
Castro you know when he was younger yeah
his mom was
yeah she was a kid see now if you want
to say she's attractive I'm on board
with this when you start going that
Pelosi route
yeah there you go now you're back now
Brian's back he's attracted there you go
very pretty look at that point right
look at her right in the middle that
middle picture right there with the
onesie right there well that one there
right there she's a sexy broad that's a
beautiful woman right there and if
you're Fidel Castro and you're a
dictator you think she was hanging out
in Cuba for what to make Cuban
sandwiches boy no you're right what do
you think he's doing with having her
around she was uh and then meanwhile her
husband's 90. yeah
that's true Stone Cold Fox it is what it
is what's going on there I don't know
what this is that looks fake it is it's
got to be fake uh I think you just sign
an autograph right but I mean this the
peach fuzz
oh oh oh I didn't even see that
wow fake news it's got to be what else
you got or it's not all right yeah well
that's it makes her less hot right this
is Zac Efron
um he's playing a wrestler like a real
life wrestler Oh Daddy
Queen daddy definitely his tummy is
sticking tummy wouldn't be that thick I
mean his tummy because your body your
tummy sticks out like that what is that
Mark
Mark I'm Gonna Leave This show if you
say he's Natty
I'm trying to it's like Mr Pelosi lover
over here yeah say he's Natty I'm gonna
break all the cameras no I just think
you tend to see this look of like
distant what we're looking at is
distension plus he's really lean so it's
like you're eating a lot of food
probably but you're also super lean it
just tends to be a look that enhanced
bodybuilders well he did the Baywatch
thing and he said he got down and forget
like six pound box seven percent body
fat he goes his most miserable I've ever
been yes I would never do that again he
was the worst gig I've ever committed to
usually I get down such low body fat and
I was barely eating every day just to
lean on camera because it was the worst
time of my life it's not like cool story
bro how about you get jacked next time
look at him there
yeah and people don't realize like even
enhance that still is difficult you know
it's not as if like taking a bunch of
stairs makes that no level you still
gotta be crazy
oh all right
um let's go to Johnny shred City huh
shred City
this happened on the 405
let me uh oh I saw this there's a man in
a wheelchair it was literally going down
the freeway
a man in a wheelchair rolls down and he
was moving too not too no not too slow
well in the middle freeway and even most
Lane five at night he switched Lanes too
the man slowing down traffic on the
south at least he's wearing a mask in
West L.A eventually changing this would
make me so annoyed this happened just
like hey dude can you not just give him
a little bump on the back of the wheels
get the [ __ ] just a little tap tap
fortunately no one was hurt and there
were no crash they said he was an
elderly man but look at him here that's
not an elderly man right he's having a
breakdown of some kind yeah
he's just going a little crazy he's
protect protect himself wearing a mask
right yeah he's just going down the 405
on a wheelchair he's having a hard time
he's all there
um this I just thought was funny I just
found this online
I can't play the audio but just check
this out this is a tree falling and look
what happens to one of the guys oh no oh
it's so dangerous right
oh
oh my God it's just so funny any other
like if that guy was younger he'd been
okay but look good there boom there you
go that was pretty funny a win for the
trees all right Marcus holy [ __ ] Mark's
coming with that tree people can't see
it but the tree fell and and then it
kind of like skated back and lifted him
up the tree falls and then like because
the bushes it hits another tree and like
goes down and then this unathletic
chubby gets under it between his legs
and throws him in the air and then he
lands on his feet and he died he died he
died yeah and the last words he says
Trudeau's Castro's kids it's weird it's
a great video we couldn't play the audio
look into it he said look into it okay
yeah well looks like I'm gonna get
dementia really how picking your nose
can increase
knuckle deep in your nose increase your
risk of developing out so this says so
Darko says for those of you listening
says how picking your nose could
increase risk of Alzheimer's and
Dementia here's the problem you run out
of Articles huh there you go nothing
else to report there you go let's do
some real reporting for us yeah
apparently it's bacteria traveling
through the nasal cavity
um to uh the olfactory nerve through the
olfactory nerve
um yeah but you have to do it for a
number of years because then every kid's
[ __ ] then dementia would be a hundred
percent yeah I've never seen a kid not
pick his [ __ ] nose
I mean yeah it's it's I'm already bored
with this dumb [ __ ] article oh dude I
went to the Rams game yesterday
yeah I haven't been a football game I
don't know how long especially NFL maybe
I don't I can't remember Broncos game
and vasco's maybe only 10 years old 12
years old I don't know that new sofa
Stadium the screen it's beautiful you
feel like you're in the movie The Avatar
it's just like this is not dude then the
food there it was like Tomahawk Prime
like steak it was like Nobu Sushi every
it was nuts mint nuts it's the most La
things I've ever seen is this the one in
Inglewood yeah the new WoW because I
went for the Rams Niners right because
Chris is an old Coliseum oh no no this
new it it is crazy really nuts
absolutely you watch a football game and
you're watching it are you watching
because you played football do you watch
uh yeah I watch the defense the schemes
you're watching I watch I watch the
tight end yeah
I just watched I realized when I watch
football I'm watching just like watching
the thing I'm watching the ball you're
watching the ball but other people who
ISO other things yeah I saw the other
things and then if there's like an
outlier like uh uh Donald Aaron Donald
I'll watch him him and then Christian
McCaffrey I used to go to when he's a
kid you did you coached Christian
McCaffrey at a camp him and his brother
damn yep so I love him what a [ __ ] and
now he's on the Niners remember deniers
are good right now right they beat the
the they beat him what's their record
right now though I forgive him uh
another there are two games above 500 I
think but then also remember they're
doing this without Debo
uh Samuels they're one of their best
players if not their best player so
they're doing it without so they're four
and four the the and now when uh Debo
comes back and then also
um homeboy uh Bosa isn't 100 either like
they're stacked everywhere man they're
they're literally man they're gonna be
problems in the playoffs especially when
Samuel comes back yeah and uh what about
the Eagles though they lost last week
but they're good no they won they lost
last week they won this week they lost
last week they date two
no I think they won Baba
I think they won
they won last week too damn they are
undefeated yeah they're seven seven and
all yeah they're they're problems look
at that division dude we thought it was
gonna be the weakest 706-2 see that's
crazy and then Washington's just a train
wreck wow though
wow how about and they were doing the
backup
his back back he had a thumb function
yeah he's back now how dude how about
the Giants uh how about Washington so
you know having Dan Snyder so the inside
of the owner right and there's been all
those allegations against him and
mistreatment and all that you know
misconduct
and then uh remember when the Roger
Goodell emails came out yeah now
remember they go through all that
they're gonna have a ton of NFL owners
information on that but they're only
released
Gruden's and Dan Snyder's Dan star's
like the [ __ ] oh I see what they're
doing so they're coming for Dan Snyder
and he was like I'm telling you because
you know there's only whatever 32 owners
31 owners he goes you come for me I'm
releasing the hounds because the
information I have on all you owners I'm
telling you I'm not going away you know
quietly and he's like I have information
on the course uh the owner of uh the
Dallas Cowboys you know everybody he was
like I'm telling you you come for me man
this can get nasty you see I'm not going
away quietly then all of a sudden stuff
starts to leak about Jerry Jones I mean
he's a billionaire you know serious
access to do that stuff yeah it's funny
I'll do the same thing oh you want to do
what after the [ __ ] I know okay
have fun all that [ __ ] all these
rich billionaires all of them just
all clean all their hands are clean yeah
right he's like we'll see how this goes
right Jerry Jones come on dude
all right Mark
all right so basically Elon Musk
believes the quickest way to turn a
profit uh with Twitter is to charge
people 20 bucks a month for the blue
check verification or if you've already
qualified for it that can keep using it
and obviously people are up in arms
about that but at the same time the
argument is like well it's a huge you
know the algorithm does Boost blue check
users and
the thinking is you're going to give
that up because you don't want to pay 20
bucks but it's also a way the way I look
at it it also keeps the Riff Raff out
right and also you know because let's
hear a community charge two dollars to
take it opposed to 30. two dollars
anybody can get it in there yeah but
this is just for the blue check so you'd
have to it's not like you can just oh so
you already verified yeah
yeah it's a way to make money yeah and
then also people that really want to be
on there I don't know everything's going
up Apple music was like hey we know we
charge 999 now it's 10.99 and then
Netflix is going up yeah Disney's
Disney's [ __ ] insane and somebody
said I'm not going to pay more for
Twitter each month than I do for Netflix
sure Sean reacts to Bryce Mitchell
what's that well Bryce Mitchell say he
didn't win the fight oh I mean you know
all right it's fine
you know
I mean no I'll also have to pick yon
overall Maryland the reason Dan is
because once again O'Malley hasn't even
earned that spot he used his mouth to
get him that fight his YouTube followers
ain't gonna help him once the cage doors
get locked
and your dad about his sister to make
you
holy [ __ ] yeah dude these kids are
savages these young kids are Savage man
you don't want to play that game he's a
bad [ __ ] right there the Bryce a
bad mother don't get twisted Sean but so
is Bryce yeah the price price at 45
though doesn't he
I think he fights at 40. yeah 45 yeah
yeah I'm just saying right says no punk
no opponent
wait you guys see that already it's a
game focker no well it's uh so uh Meet
the Parents reference the controversy
here is that it's a trans uh you know
male to female spikes the ball hits this
girl in the head let me see it go back
it'll have to play on its own
[Music]
causing severe head injuries here we go
it's over there
no it's not as if it was that fast or
some crazy [ __ ] you talking about
Juwanna Man in the corner yeah so if
that's your daughter I'm like hey [ __ ]
face of course who let Juwanna Man play
like if now listen we're here we don't
have spearhead neck injuries you know
[ __ ] you [ __ ] you letting like uh a
biological male into female sports I'm
totally against it 100 I'm totally
against you now they should be able to
play volleyball have Biden like talking
about how kids should have be able to
have puberty blockers and stuff like
that and see how that how you doing in
your [ __ ] uh and I'll vote against
anybody who says that regardless of
whether they're Republican Democrat I'm
just voting against you Republicans are
saying that no I know
[ __ ] you know who's saying that
Pelosi yeah and you're like yeah I want
to kiss [ __ ] off oh you [ __ ] off for
that
all right next one I think it really
affects you when you know your kids
playing and they're like hey yeah yeah
you remember Zach Zach's Mary now and
he's number 44. you know it's [ __ ] so
annoying all right it's unbelievable oh
no
oh this is the best so the climate
change protesters vandalized Ferraris in
a car show hold on this is gonna hold on
yeah I'm gonna this trigger they they
they glued their hands to the Ferrari
this is really good you know what kind
of fry that is so I have a 430. that's a
430 skedara there's about 600 in the
world
dude that's going to make the planet
cool if you glue your hands to a Ferrari
the plan is going to be good I've
already called a few degrees is that
what happened yeah oh yeah you know what
that's gonna make me I want to pollute
more now now I want to pollute more now
I want to just walk around with a big
Diesel and then let me just ask these
morons right who put their hands on this
piece of art and if that was my card hey
you're not getting close I'd leave him
there just leave him there I'll just
start myself like cool oh cool I'm just
gonna start my car because this is your
your violating property I'm starting my
car let's see how your hand feels well
they did that they did that they glued
their hands to a Porsche Factory our
Porsche dealership and nobody came to
get them and they had to pee and [ __ ]
and they just left [ __ ] Japan yeah
that's what we're going to do now here's
the thing let me ask these more on this
why aren't you protesting Tesla you know
the engines and Tesla are harder on the
environment around this correct so
you're correct it makes no you have no
defense because they're not very
thoughtful no because they're not very
smart no if you like Teslas that's fine
but if you think in your bite because
you're better than me because of my gas
powered you're so far off so funny
man they they penalized dude that's not
any Ferrari Brian that's a V8 skodero
okay how much is that does that what no
no no no that that car you probably get
for uh low 300s
it's going up in value a work of art
only 600 of them if you have them if you
get the 16m there's one but he's just
it's just glue if it's convertible if
that's a convertible 16m there's only
300 on the floor
oh it's a convertible it's a 16m I feel
sick
foreign
that one in the middle is a challenge
annoying is
all right keep doing that [ __ ] keep that
same energy now how many do you guys
want to how do you think those people
are doing in life if you have the time
to glue yeah really well really well
because that's a great way to raise
awareness now now I just want more
global warming I like it that it's warm
and I also am not so sure I buy any of
it anyway
I think the earth I think the Earth is
warming maybe but I think I've had I've
listened to real climatology scientists
like real people who study this who are
real scientists who are like could also
be solar flares and you doing stuff with
your cars isn't going to make a liquid
no but there's also something to it
where they when they do research like
thousands of years ago the earth goes in
these ways or it gets hotter colder
hotter colder we're just right now I
mean so
but I'll tell you what though when I'm
in the when I walk outside my house the
middle of summer it's 120 I'm like it
might be right yeah I don't know I was
in Chicago and it was 75 degrees I had
my shirt off so I don't know yeah I have
a nice body
[Music]
yeah the Calgary was cold it is not
global warming Calgary is so cold you
can't believe there's no snow but
Calgary gets so cold you can't believe
it it's one of the coolest places in the
world but in the wintertime it's a
[ __ ] nightmare
you're not ready what else you guys got
all right here we go
squirrels yeah let's do it
so 150 kilograms of eggs
oh that's so awesome imagine all the
trips you'd have to make to get them up
here those squirrels they're looking at
like what the [ __ ] that's so bad all the
Years bro I know right what a [ __ ]
squirrel he's a billionaire of squirrels
that's a billionaire squirrel that
squirrel's like why would you do this
the richest squirrel on Earth
well I know kids come see me in you lost
all energy huh I lost all energy yes
you're not using uh uh Magic mine I
didn't take mine Charlotte North
Carolina Comedy Zone uh November 10 11
12 Addison Improv uh Addison November 17
18 19 Naples Florida off the hook
December one to four
um then in you don't see it but December
8 9 and 10 I'm at Nyack in New York
supposed to be a great Club at Lebanese
live and then laugh Boston go and get
that night I date up there though huh
let's do that please yeah uh your boys
headed to Texas two weeks in a row San
Antonio Texas November 3rd through the
5th that's this Thursday Friday Saturday
I will be at my favorite Hotel of all
time Hotel Emma we also have all the
thick nectar that tiger thick will be
available in masses because Texas is the
biggest Market my friends at specs you
can go get balls at specs so I'm in San
Antonio come try some of that sweet
thick nectar award-winning sick uh tiger
thick nectar and uh that's LOL Santo
this Thursday Friday Saturday next week
Houston I will be doing my parents at
specs giving out samples of the
award-winning tiger thick that's
November 10th through the 12th Houston
Improv I end November Milwaukee improv
is November 18th through the 19th and
then December uh yeah I end uh the oh he
thick tour in Providence Rhode Island
December 1st through the 3rd never been
looking forward to it and one of my
favorite clubs Washington DC DC Improv
December 15th through the 17th get you
some new merch drops Friday thick boy
diet merch drops Friday as well I think
that's it kids we love you guys also
just a heads up we've been told by our
YouTube Team experts on YouTube we're
dropping the video too late
um so we're switching so this will come
out now on Tuesday mornings but audio
will be available as usual Tuesday
Morning Tuesday at 1 Tuesday to be
available Tuesday we're figuring it out
but Tuesday early you'll be able to see
the the YouTube episodes audio's will be
available right away a little change
there so and the Wednesdays comes out on
Thursday Wednesday comes out Thursday
yep yep yep instead of dropping so late
all right kids we love you guys bye bye